es gab einen anschlag auf die berliner
museumsinsel mehrere kunstwerke wurden
dabei zerstört es ging schon
es bessert alles schon am dritten
oktober stattgefunden 70 kunstwerke und
antiken wurden beschädigt die täter sind
unbekannt
polizei und museen schwiegen bisher der
deutschlandfunk und die zeit berichten
ein oder mehrere unbekannte täter
bespritzten mindestens 70 objekte im
pergamonmuseum im neuen museum in der
alten nationalgalerie und an anderen
standorten mit einer öligen flüssigkeit
wie die täter trotz überwachungskameras
vorgehen konnten
das ist bisher unklar und warum die
kunst ziel von zerstörungen wurde auch
dazu wird jetzt ermittelt besonders
pikant verschwörungs fanatiker attila
hildmann hatte mehrfach verbreitet dass
das pergamonmuseum den thron des satans
beherberge und ist das zentrum der
globalen satanisten szene und corona
verbrecher sei was meinen denn
verschwörungstheoretiker damit wenn sie
vom thron des satans sprechen der sich
im pergamon museum befinden soll
ja wo dieser frage habe ich wirklich
angst gehabt kannst du dir vorstellen
weil er
könnte das erklären außer attila
hildmann ich will es mal versuchen es
ist natürlich jedem denkenden menschen
total klar dass der teufel nicht im
pergamon museum auf dem auf dem
pergamonaltar wohnte dass dort nicht
menschen opfer in der nacht stattfinden
attila hildmann sieht das aber wohl so
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe bei
verschwörungstheoretikern ist es aber
manchmal ein bisschen schwer das zu
verstehen aber wie gesagt für wittmann
ist das ganze das zentrum des bösen des
statistischen deshalb ja
das so das ganze liegt aber
wahrscheinlich eher profan darin
begründet dieser museums hast weil er zu
anfang der korona pandemie hat er dort
nebenan beim alten museum auf die stufen
kundgebungen veranstaltet das wurde dann
aber verboten mittlerweile hängt dort
ein plakat als ein großes transparent
was gegen fremdenfeindlichkeit und
überhaupt also gegen alles was man so
propagiert richtet und darf dort eben
nicht mehr sein und ich glaube es das
irgendwie ein etwas fehlgeleiteter
persönlicher groll und hass der dann ins
wahnsinnige ungeschlagen ist und deshalb
gegen den pergamonaltar hetzen lässt und
vermutlich in seiner ideologie dann
irgendetwas sucht was
bisschen größer klingt als einfach nur
ein persönlicher abneigung
gegen die museen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren